plus que jamais la thèse de l'accident
dû au verglas et privilégier aucune
trace d'alcoolémie ni de produits
stupéfiants n'ont été détectés sur les
chauffeurs les temps de conduite et la
vitesse réglementaire semble respectée
mais des vérifications techniques plus
poussées sont en cours seule
interrogation savoir si le chauffeur
portait sa ceinture de sécurité
pour l'heure pas de réponse car le
conducteur qui était au volant moment
des faits n'a pas encore été auditionné
il doit être opéré dans les heures à
venir
son collègue a par contre été hier soir
brièvement placé prend garde
tout simplement pour vérifier les temps
de conduite vérifier les circonstances
éventuel il a pu confirmer qu'il ne
conduisait pas et que pour lui il n'y
avait rien d'anormal au moment de
l'accident il dormait lui même et il
indique simplement qu'il a vu le bus
quitté la chaussée traverser la chaussée
mais il n'ya pas que les conducteurs qui
font l'objet de l'attention des
enquêteurs
les passagers sont également concernés
on le sait certains ne portaient pas
leur ceinture de sécurité et ont été
éjectés nous avons pu commencer à
entendre un certain nombre de passagers
du bus mais pas tous pour le moment
certains sont encore hospitalisés et
dans un deuxième temps les enquêteurs
vont saisir un expert automobile pour
faire un certain nombre de vérifications
sur le bus et l' enquête sera
particulièrement focalisé sur la
remorque à bagages tractée par le bus
était elle en surcharge
il n'y a pas encore de réponse en tout
cas aucune information judiciaire n'est
encore ouverte
c'est une enquête préliminaire qui se
déroule actuellement